en conferencia de prensa el
seleccionador nacional fernando santos
aseguró que cristiano ronaldo se
encuentra bien totalmente asintomático
anclado en un cuarto desde la noche de
este lunes cuando resultó positivo a
kobe 19 que el propio ronaldo no tiene
claro cómo contrajo el virus y que lo
único que dice es que quiere jugar a
juicio del entrenador no sería con la
selección portuguesa que se contagio
pues en los últimos siete días se
realizaron seis pruebas consecutivas y
en todas
todos los jugadores resultaron negativos
hasta el día de ayer que cristiano
ronaldo dio positivo ser una baja
sensible para el partido que va a
disputar portugal contra suecia este
miércoles como parte de la liga de las
naciones cristiano ronaldo es el tercer
jugador de la selección nacional en dar
positivo a kobe recordemos los dos casos
anteriores
jose fonte y anto ni lópez actualmente
él se encuentra dentro de la ciudad de
fútbol de este complejo deportivo de 7
hectáreas que se encuentra en oeiras a
las afueras de lisboa allí va a
permanecer hasta esperar los resultados
de la nueva prueba se está a la
espectativa de más de cristiano ronaldo
se podrá incorporar
a la juventus en los próximos días para
disputar el partido contra el barcelona
como parte de la champions